i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story my name is nick frazier but
you may know me from the water line me
this all started in the year 2015. i
feel like i'm about to tell a story like
from a book
i was driving
to 7-eleven to get some donuts and gummy
bears we shout out to 7-eleven they got
the best gummy bears just in case you
needed to know that and as i was driving
i had the bluetooth of my iphone
connected to the car and then comes on
too close by next so when the song
starts to play you know it's one of my
favorite songs and i start singing it
baby why are you crying
i get so excited it's not crying it's
grinding oh see i didn't even know that
baby when you're grinding wow that's
crazy after all these years nobody told
me this whole time i'm saying crying
you should actually leave that in can we
put that in so i'm driving i'm singing
i'm saying i'm singing i said wait a
minute i just heard myself saying lion
instead of anything else and then
suddenly you know i just started
remembering there's this kid that i went
to high school with you know i'm not
going to disclose the information
but this is a kid i'm with the high
school with that
he used to lie about things he had cars
clothes that people knew he didn't have
but he just kept lying just to form
conversation with us we used to call him
out like why are you lying about that
like why bro if you're watching this and
you know that i'm talking about you you
don't have to lie bro it was cool enough
come on and i felt like
me saying the song kind of like those
memories just triggered in my head
that's why it just came out that way why
you always lying
no my god i did all of that in the car
while i was driving so i'm driving as if
this is a song that's already out so as
i'm doing that i'm like oh yeah it's
over the next day i woke up early and
got a haircut i got the part in my hair
which i don't have right now came back
home and then i was looking through my
closet for a shirt that you know scream
90s r b music video type that's actually
my brother's shirt and he was never able
to wear that shirt again after that day
the location was my backyard i called my
brother i'm like yo can you come outside
real quick i want to film something why
the [ __ ] you lying
why you always lying
oh my god
stop [ __ ] lying i didn't plan the
moves i was really just feeling it like
you know like in those old 90s r b
videos where it's just like a bop it
just took over my body that toilet was
actually a new toilet that my mother
bought and it didn't work when we
installed it into the house so we just
put it outside and left it on the side
probably for a few months before i did
what i did with it and then ever since
it just stayed there i just realized
this is a historical artifact so we
can't really get rid of this i sat in
the darkness for about two hours maybe
editing the sound the volume so once i
put it out i left my phone alone you
know the next day my notifications were
going so crazy from vine that i had to
get a new phone because my phone was
overheating and then everything just
started circulating news on twitter
tumblr instagram facebook guardian
buzzfeed complex bet rolling stone
everywhere you could possibly think of
it was on it and as i'm scrolling
through my instagram i'm seeing my face
over and over and over and over and over
again i'm just like wait what's going on
right now there was a lot of people like
wow this is me i know somebody like this
they were tagging certain people this is
you it didn't really hit me until
somebody sent me a video of it being
played on the radio i knew it was going
to be something but i didn't think that
it would hit the way that it did and
influenced people the way that it did i
actually did meet the original creators
next i was on an episode of uncommon
sense by charlemagne they had me out
there with him and we were both you know
singing and dancing with it so it was a
very full circle moment that was that
was pretty dope that they did that i
never really kept in touch with the kid
from high school i actually do have a
mess with him i hope whatever it is that
you're doing in life right now you just
decided you know the stories is not
really worth it the folk tales are not
really worth it you know just just be
yourself just talk regularly if you've
got you got it if you don't got it you
don't got it it's calm just stop
[Music]
[Music]
you